so we've been covering the two recent
airplane crashes of the Boeing 737 eight
max there was one in October of 2018
Lyon air which is an Indonesian airline
and then there was a second crash more
recently an Ethiopian Airlines crash and
similar patterns in both sort of erratic
altitude changes shortly after takeoff
and the planes are now grounded
indefinitely worldwide over what is
believed to be a software issue rather
than I guess what you would call an air
worthiness issue and this is really big
I mean it's tragic in that hundreds of
people died and that in and of itself no
matter what else is going on is a major
thing it's big because airlines are
starting to transition over to the 737
max and its various iterations the 737
has been the sort of workhorse airplane
for the planet for decades and
eventually the idea is that old 737s the
737-800 and other versions of it will be
replaced with these different versions
of the 737 max the max eight nine and
ten I believe they are 5000 of these new
737 maxes have been ordered so far 371
have been delivered so far all 371 are
currently grounded so the disruptive
effect to airline operations and the
people's travel is huge but of course
necessary because you've got to keep
people safe when you know that there's a
problem the United States Justice
Department has now issued multiple
subpoenas into how the 737 max obtained
FAA certification to begin with and how
they have marketed the planes to
Airlines this is now a criminal
investigation a question that they're
asking or want to answer is exactly how
did Boeing present the plane as safe and
what data was used was the data accurate
or could there be criminal wrongdoing in
what was done there we don't actually
know right now what criminal laws could
be at issue it's unclear but we will
ultimately see and this has now crossed
over into what is being called a
potential criminal investigation and
that in and of itself is
huge we're also now learning and this is
just stunning that the day before the
lion air crash there was a pilot who was
flying on the lion air airplane that
crashed in the cockpit but in the jump
seat in other words this pilot was not
working as a pilot on that flight but
was flying in the jump seat maybe to get
back to where they next had to fly out
of who-knows-what in any case that pilot
was aware of this particular problem
and knew exactly which system had to be
disabled in order to prevent the plane
from starting these erratic altitude
changes and he was in the cockpit when
this problem started on that same lion
air aircraft that ultimately crashed the
day before thanks to the luck of him
being in the cockpit he immediately told
the pilots that were in command which
system to disable and what to do and it
arguably we believe prevented the lion
air air plane from crashing the day
before it actually did next day the
different crew flies that same aircraft
this pilot with knowledge of exactly
which system needs to be disabled is not
flying is not in the cockpit and we know
that the plane crashed and killed
everybody that was on board we didn't
know this until recently and this
suggests and I don't know if this is
tragically or not that pilots may have
been more aware of exactly what this
risk was than has been initially
reported and that the crew that was
flying on the day of the lion air crash
simply didn't know which system it was
that needed to be disabled in order to
respond to this malfunction so listen I
mean I I try to be very careful not to
react more significantly than is
warranted by the facts commercial
aviation in general is extraordinarily
safe but if these planes were not
currently grounded I wouldn't be flying
on them right
now and I understand that statistically
up until their grounding most Boeing 737
eight max --is took off and landed
without incident completely safe safely
and more than likely if I were to fly on
one even without this issue being fixed
I would probably be fine but there's a
very specific problem that's been
identified there have been two crashes
and I wouldn't get on one of these
planes and I know last time I said this
people emailed in and said David you're
probably still fine and the truth is
that even if you were flying on an
Airbus 320 you'd still have a greater
chance of being killed while driving to
the airport that's fine but it's sort of
a non sequitur the risk of driving to
the airport is not affected by the risk
of what airline airliner you were going
to be flying on and if it weren't
grounded I wouldn't be flying right now
on the Boeing 737 max I am flying on one
of the older 737s in a couple of weeks
but not the max I'm flying on Delta to
Las Vegas I don't even think that they
are using the max but I think that my
conclusion is similar to most people in
the audience which is that they would
not fly on the max at this point in time
and I'm confident that this is going to
be figured out it's not going to make
the two accidents any less tragic
there's no way of undoing that and now
that this criminal component has been
introduced
who knows what direction the
investigation would take and what it
means for boeing and in the back of this
there's the political stuff that we know
Trump spoke to the Boeing CEO around the
time that the grounding decision was
made in the United States and there's
potentially all sorts of political stuff
at play if you opened the door to
suspicious FAA approvals although at
this point in time we have an inquiry
but we don't have evidence that anything
unusual happened in terms of the
approval and certification of this
particular aircraft
it'll be figured out when I don't know
send me your thoughts would you fly on a
Boeing 737 a max eight at this point in
time if it were not grounded I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
one of today's david pakman show
sponsors is simple habit an app that
provides a massive library of really
excellent five minute guided meditations
they're letting everybody in our
audience use it completely free for one
week when you go to simple habit calm
slash Pakman we've talked a lot on the
program about the growing scientific
evidence pointing to the benefits of
meditation and what really sets simple
habit apart is the variety of guided
meditations that they offer more than
2,000 made for many different issues
that you may be dealing with if you need
help falling asleep if you have anxiety
that you're dealing with if you want to
be more productive during the day they
have meditations specifically tailored
for certain times of day like when
you're waking up or your commute to work
or when you've just gotten home from
work I'm a huge advocate of meditation
myself I've really enjoyed integrating
simple habit into my day and each
meditation takes just five minutes and
they're very easy to follow maybe you
want to feel more grounded before you
start your day at work or at school
maybe you want to keep your mind a
little more clear so that it's easier to
accomplish your goals or you just want a
calmer more peaceful experience
throughout your day simple habit can
help you get there it just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app it's available on Android iOS and
web browser and you can try it
completely free for a week check it out
go to simple habit calm slash Pakman
I've put a link down below underneath
the video